do you guys consider yourselves to be
conservatives i would say
i'm i'm more i mean i'm trying to just
provide like unbiased news
like i've never voted before i still
haven't voted like i'm not registered
not even
political yeah i'm not really you know
political um i don't what would you say
shelby yeah i'm
i'm i think that's in because people
just assume
that we're uber conservative because of
you know who we're associated with
i would say none of us are really i mean
i know richie's politics richie voted
for who
you can go ahead he's going to say it
well yeah i did i
voted for barack obama oh i voted for
obama the first time yeah you voted for
the
second time i did wow i
i didn't regret the first time but you
know i was 18 years old i just moved to
washington dc
but the second time yeah i do i
definitely regret it but yeah i think
just i'm more of an
anti-establishmentarian you know i
i saw the bush years i saw the clinton
years growing up and i really saw a
problem with
both sides of the establishment and
barack obama really
he did run on a platform of hope and
change it's just that
you know once he got into office clearly
he was kind of sucked into that
establishment
so i mean i would consider yeah myself
an anti-establishmentarian yeah
yeah i would say i mean i before i
started this i started uh
as a journalist in 2019 and i um before
that i played professional tennis for
four years
and before that i you know played d1 at
university of iowa
so i was sports and i was hardly even in
america
so i had no idea what was going on in
american politics
so i didn't grow up being actually when
i first got my job my
my aunt uh we call her girl kelly she'll
be happy
i gave her a shout out um but we she was
shocked that i was going into politics
and and i but i think that has allowed
me to really um see both sides like i
genuinely do feel like i
um can understand both sides of the
spectrum and therefore
i i do try really hard um in my
reporting
you know if it's peaceful it's peaceful
some of these people have legitimate
things i think i think a lot of what we
hear is is
from the protesters and the unresters
there are real legitimate problems and
to be solved the problem is
when you have like if someone comes to
me and says black lives matter i'll be
like
absolutely i don't know where do we go
from there like what do you want to do
you know
if you tell me that somebody got shot
and they shouldn't have let's talk about
it because
cops should not be executing people if
it is like a murder
if it's the instance where it's like a
fight breaks out and someone's
struggling with cops like i don't know
what we're supposed to do
you know what i mean like with jacob
blake for instance like he was fighting
with cops
he had a knife and he was apparently you
know the
stealing woman's car he wanted on a
felony warrant and she was yelling
according to the lawyer he's got my kids
he's got my keys
and so what's the cop suppose how does
cop supposed to respond to this guy
who's wanted on a felony warrant doing
these things
it's a challenge the problem i see is i
got no problem sitting down with with
with a trump supporting conservative
who's like
you know yelling blue lives matter and
we got to respect the cops i'm going to
be like
i absolutely agree for a society to
function cops got to be able to make
arrests even if
sometimes they make mistakes it can be
really annoying but you deal with the
process after the fact
and there you you don't fight with them
but then the other side is like burn it
all down
destroy you know the abolish police
defund police and it's like
it's it's it's so far removed from a
reasonable approach to how we deal with
it
you know what i mean yeah it's been it's
just been a crazy situation i think
for you know me and shelby or anyone
doing this work like for me
um like i was in sports journalism
before i got it you know the whole
political thing and then anyway you're
both sports
yeah yeah no like yeah she played in the
game i was more than the sidelights guy
but like i didn't even know what a
republican or democrat was to like 2018
i fully switch you then now that i
started reporting on you know a lot of
these protests and marches
unrest unrest un-wrestlers um i'll have
people from my hometown
you know message me message me and be
like why are you
you know why are you portraying black
lives matter the movement like this
and i and i literally have to be like i
didn't have i didn't have no idea it was
like
i was on the ground like i didn't know
they were attacking press and like
attacking business owners and doing this
to i was on the ground you know like
you know i'm not there's no narrative
here we just literally we just hit
record
we upload it and then everyone else you
know gets to form their own opinion on
the video i think that's
a strength that we really have the daily
call that you can't really find in other
places
i do want to say just real quick though
um i think that's
what you touched on is really important
that's why we all work at the caller
which is
people don't realize they just assume oh
you work at the daily caller you're like
a conservative and you know
you're tucker carlson basically and
that's really not the case there's
there's such a multitude of political
ideologies
of people who work at the daily caller
and the newsroom is really just like a
place where
everybody hashes that out any story that
comes up in the news that's
complicated or difficult we're just
talking about it with uncensored
straight up and when i worked at nbc
news uh that was the opposite it was
like a funeral totally
yup yeah and shelby and i were talking
about this because we fight all the time
when we're on the road
little fights though little fights
flickering but at nbc
once a year the people have been working
together for 30 years and they've kept
it all bottled up for 30 years
pops off and it's just a meltdown so i
like nervousness i think i scared
some of the rioters in kenosha i started
screaming at ritchie
in public yeah at like midnight
uh he wanted me to follow him around
like a little puppy dog because he was
nervous because i'm a woman
i got myself in trouble actually and
then he got himself yeah
so so uh when you mentioned you wouldn't
recommend it
i i agree don't go to jail yes but there
is something
to like we're too comfortable
you know like young young people in this
country don't understand how bad things
could be
and that includes many of these
protesters who are like burn it all down
defund this abolish this and i don't
mean all of them
because i know like there are regular
people who just are angry about police
brutality and stuff
though i think they're being manipulated
for sure these people have never
experienced real hardship that's why
it's funny to me when
like you you mentioned that some of the
women are crying and some of them are
just like well this is what's happening
yeah you can i i i'd be willing to bet
the women who are like this is what's
happening
are the people who have actually
experienced something hard and they and
they've been toughened up and they
understand
you're gonna be okay you don't like you
don't need to worry about this stuff
so like i remember when you know ever
every time i've been
arrested more than once i just like all
right you know
i'm not gonna die in a jail cell i'm not
gonna it's gonna be a day or something
it's
and then i you know nothing ends up
happening on it it's just i got some
bunk arrests skateboarding you know they
wanna
they don't like skateboarders but that
but there's there are many circumstances
i've been in
where you can clearly tell people who
have who are who are wads of cookie
dough who are
you know marshmallows and the people who
have actually experienced real hardship
so it's it's it's really great i did uh
i don't know have you guys have done any
hospital environment training
no this is fun unless you count like
growing up with my family
where did you grow up in new york not
probably one of five
yeah i got salvador in paris my mom is a
prosecutor so
you can imagine she used to tell us
democracy stops at the front door oh man
that's awesome
so i i had been covering civil unrest
riots when i say civil unrest i mean
like border around revolution i mean in
the literal sense not dislike we're not
going to call protesters protests
uh so i've covered protests unrest like
actual revolution
and rioting and so when i started
working for the abc news company
they were like everybody's got to have
hostile environment training and
i was like i should be giving the
training because i've been doing this
you know for x many years and most of
these people
like the even the people who are doing
the training don't have the most
up-to-date understanding of the modern
technology and what's going on
and you know i got a a whisper wink wink
it's the insurance company dude
like insurance company wants all the
reporters to have special training
but i tell you what man when we were
doing the training they paired me up
with uh
a former marine fresh out of the marines
and we
they could not get us so like the way
these trainings work is like they have
fake land mines
you know so they like they put these
things in the ground that are hidden and
when you step on it it sprays
you know ink or something and they're
like oh you got landmine and there are a
bunch of
scenarios where they try and get you and
it was a lot of fun it's
really fun the way these so like uh i
got to participate as
a local villager and they do this thing
where they have the news crew come
in and then that's all they do and they
tell
us you know because like it's your turn
to play the villagers i pick pocketed
people it was amazing i was like
taking their stuff and they were
panicking but when i was there with the
marine
it was really amazing because we
actually escaped their final
terrorist scenario so they did the
scenario where our world
like your your assignment now from the
editor is to interview the leader of a
terrorist organization
and we're gonna go everything's been
arranged your security is with you
and it was really cool like the suv
pulls up we hear gunshots
and then like we see people on the
ground me and the marine guy were gone
like we were out of there and then we
hear from a distance where'd you go
and we're laughing and i'm like this guy
gets it and then
and then but but it was so bunk because
the trainer guy goes you guys are dead
and we started laughing and they're like
come back and we we came back and they
were like
you uh you you you got uh the terrorists
killed you
and i was like dude we immediately both
went for dead ground and we immediately
serpentined through trees we were gone
and we know it
because this guy this guy knows the
marine dude knows better than i do
but i was like we we were we were
laughing in the woods hearing them in
the distance upset that we like beat
their training
so anyway i bring that up just because
like when you're on the ground
and you guys probably know this too like
with you you can you can see
when you see journalists or whatever
which one of them has actually got
experience and which ones are like the
local desk reporter who was asked to go
out and film this stuff
because i'll tell you what man when i
was in ferguson there's a couple things
i love
two instances in ferguson where gunshots
are ringing out
and i'm on the deck and then i look up
and i see one of these local reporters
going
are those fireworks and then one of my
one of my favorite all-time blunders is
from cnn
when they were in ferguson and the
gunshots go off and it's this woman and
she goes
what oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh and she's just like waving her
arms and like i'm like
stop standing there waving your arms
they're shooting bullets
get on the ground and then she just like
hobbles over like behind a building and
i'm like
oh my gosh when i was the first the
first shots that went off when i was in
ferguson
i was standing by uh one of the shops in
the parking lot
and we heard we heard a shot
and then i heard another shot and i
immediately just dove
like i'm not i'm like i like belly flop
i put my hands down slid and i heard the
whip crack over my head the bullet hit
the building
so the like being on the ground and
seeing these people who are sent out by
local news like they have no experience
no idea what to do
i'm not surprised they're like well we
got here at 7 50 we recorded our five
minute hit and let's go home
you're good you shouldn't be there yeah
but then it is really weird that you see
like
like especially with you guys in kenosha
because all the footage out of kenosha
you don't see any reporters anywhere
it's just literally people running
around and all this chaos
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you